allez les enfants on va se coucher on se
plaît à laisse nous regarder les garçons
je vous ai dit pas regarder ce genre de
trucs avant de dormir
allez hop au lit ça existe pas maman on
risque rien
vous croyez au mal aux forces occultes
oui j'y crois on ne peut pas arrêter le
mal on ne peut que tenter de s'en
protéger
super pour dylan pourquoi je sais quoi
il a changé
j'ai un truc à te montrer on trouve des
allusions à ce bagoul dans toutes les
cultures
on raconte qu'il se nourrit de la
corruption de l'innocence
il y a toujours trois éléments une
famille assassinée une maison et une
offrande
qu'est ce qu'elle dit elle donne des
coordonnées de quel lieu une ferme où
toute une famille a été assassinée on
voit jamais personne par ici c'est
horrible ce qui s'est passé les enfants
il agit à travers eux sur la selle bien
notre famille est en danger pourquoi il
va nous faire du match de promettre l'en
empêcher
m